thank you for being with us
and thank you so much i love being here
with you sharing with this community
with all of you so so nice let's begin
with this experience that i have had
working and playing with vite so let me
tell you and let's begin
so first of all who am i okay
oscar barajas
best known as gndx in social networks
and i am passionate about teaching about
technology and yes about javascript even
though i
also like other programming languages
and i work with all the ecosystem
so why am i here i have had experience
and the satisfaction to work with
javascript from a long time ago i
started in web development from 2001 so
in july this year i have 20 years
working in the ecosystem of web
development living through these updates
that we know thanks to the history
of all that is behind these technologies
and part of them are also part of me
some others i did not meet but i am
still a passionate uh
passionate for these languages and
content creation
and also teaching within web development
so i am going to talk to you about my
experience and what i do in this
environment so now you see my baby
who is called oscar david barajas and we
hope to take him in the next step of
development
so let's begin with these topics that
have to do with the importance
but first i want to invite you to tweet
and add gndx and use the jsconf mx
because if you send some tweets about
how you're living this amazing
experience that we're having at jsconf i
am going to be showing these tweets so
i want to see
how you're living this experience your
questions and everything you want to
share and you can do it right now
because here in the integration we're
going to do it and i'm going to tell you
a secret about why i'm asking this from
you so let's go on with this talk that i
have prepared for you first
let's talk about javascript
so it is well known that javascript was
created in the middle of the browser
battle a long time ago
back then when we had netscape navigator
against internet explorer and at that
time we lived a revolution and a battle
for winning access internet access
through a browser
several technologies were born there
that nowadays we are using and thanks to
that we have javascript but of course
here we also have some things to
consider
and it is well known that it was created
in record time and with some details to
take into account and
it is what we
love and hate about javascript but let's
not worry about that about those little
details that perhaps will make us
remember some things that we do not
really like about javascript
but there is something that
i want you to have in mind and those are
concepts that are going to be hard for
us because we are not used to
understanding them the that way
these are these acronyms these elements
that may or may not have meaning to you
and which are key
so why
that are key to know what vite is
nowadays so here we can understand the
tool correctly and how this comes to
change things
why is it the future and why this is
going to change the way we are going to
work within
web development so i want you to
understand concepts such as common gs or
cjs
which is going to allow us to have a
module system
that is inspired in node.js and that we
have used and we recognize some words
which are require and export so
we have comments
and we are going to see it in detail
then we have another concept which are
going to find which is amd which is
confusing because what does processor
have to do with this but i mentioned
this because of course i have had this
question like what does amd has to do it
is not related to processors but it is
about the concept of a synchronous model
definition
that allows us to
have this division between what was
considered common gis but work with the
part of asynchronous work so we are
going to
use that in require.js so that is
important
another topic is umd or in this case
universal module definition is a way in
which we mix these concepts of common js
and amd
to have a way in which we can work and
this is before
the ecmascript which is the standard
that regulates our favorite programming
language javascript showed what is now
ecmascript modules
which is within this review in 2015 and
it is known as es6
and here we start to import our
resources and have several elements such
as the export which are key nowadays and
can work correctly with our browsers and
our applications
and since we understand these concepts
in this summary i want you to keep them
later and to save them for the main part
which
will allow us to understand
the particularities so now that we're
here in the topic let's begin
to talk about what i want to work with
or what i want you to understand about
bite what is fight many people ask so
what it is what does it mean how is it
done why is it here
so let me tell you that byte is a tool
thought by
frontend who is created by evan you so
who who is this man tell me more
avenue is the creator of vue.js
is one of the frameworks that is within
this framework wire which i call it
and here they are fighting react angular
and also view so evan you created this
tool
directly to work within view but not
only for this point this is something
also very interesting and this is
because thanks to hit this developer we
have a very powerful tool that will
allow us to create javascript
applications using a framework
and it's going to allow us to be able to
work without any trouble to be very fast
because the word bite is very fast in
french or it comes from that context so
we're talking about
being very fast very quick and this is
one of the things that this resource is
focused on in performance speed
and that which we are going to take
advantage of as professionals and that's
that's something to think about so byte
is not just thought for view this is
very important to
think about this is not view exclusive
it's not only going to be there let me
tell you that yes it is available so
that you can prepare your projects with
the main
tools that we are using today such as
angular react spelt
and vanilla javascript you can work with
other elements and resources within
typescript and also view
but of course they are very well
integrated as well as other tools
which are going to allow us to have a
great amount of these
tools which are very popular within
front end and to be able to be
implemented in this tool which is going
to give us
super powers to create applications with
our faster
with some characteristics
that are going to the node changes that
in our work in which we are going to
build our applications and with that
advanced professionally
taking advantage of this tool so let's
talk about the characteristics and why
do i
want you to consider that and the
features
is what
leads us into the future towards the
tool that is going to change the way in
which we're working
and the way in which we're playing with
elements
and here we have some important
characteristics such as instant server
start
which is going to allow us a service and
internal service
on demand
through ecmascript modules which is
native and that is the keyword it's
native is incorporated within the
resource and we are going to be able to
work
faster
in our applications and we are also
going to implement this concept
about our tools our favorite tools to
build
so
this is one of the things that is going
to give us an advantage and i want to
stop here for a moment because when
we're working with our applications or
when we're playing with some element
within what we want to create as pros
we need to have this versatility to work
very fast to test so that the changes
and the elements flow so that our time
is well used so that this feature is
present within this resource is going to
be essential so that we don't have to
have a large setup and we can start
working directly
another thing that we have to think
about is all this part about hot module
replacement
which is going to allow us
to make this element faster with
dependencies specific dependencies that
we're going to be working on
so having all these resources without
having to wait
that the server is preparing our
application and every change that we're
making is immediate
and of course fast is going to
not make us having to wait for
compilation and in the example i always
make a lot of times
sometimes we are making a change we make
a typo and we see that the change is
failing and we have to go back and that
is
a lot of time and we'll waste that time
and that time
well it is our professional
responsibility so having
this tool optimized tool that will allow
us to work without issue is going to be
the key and this is something that i
really like a lot
so another element that we will find is
these great features that are
incorporated and remember that we as
professionals love to mix technologies
love to work with the trends
with what's happening today and here
we need to say that byte incorporates
elements that have to do with typescript
css and it allows us to work correctly
with the great tools that we are already
incorporating or mixing these
technologies which i mentioned before so
that you can take advantage of that for
your project and they are incorporated
within the core of the tool
so this is important to consider because
it will allow us to have projects with
the standards with the highest standards
that we want to implement within our
projects so this is one of the great
tools that personally i like a lot and
it is the acceptance on typescript so
this is something that we have to
emphasize a lot
another element that i really love
is the optimized build which is that
this is going to work with the ecommerce
script modules to be working correctly
and something interesting about this is
that it optimizes a lot because it's
working with concepts and
implementations that it has worked with
before isolated with other projects so
we can implement resources
otherwise other somewhere else and it
will allow us to optimize our projects
which is going to be faster and the
great advantages is that we
get much performance in this area and
these tools are not thought for
javascript but
they we are using processes from other
programming languages
within this go use so with
when we use these resources within the
tool we're going to be able to take
advantage of it for our projects so
from completing an application a very
robust
application
and we will reduce the time drastically
so this is one of the characteristics
that i really like i have been
experimenting with that and trying to
understand because we're going to be
more advantageous for us for projects
and personally i like is i like it a lot
another characteristic is that we have
plugins
so bytes enhances uh some plugins which
with which we can work but we also have
a superset and we have a great community
and this is something that i really love
the community is always so important
because we have developers and that the
community is supported supporting each
other we have these
plugins that can be added and we can
have take more advantage of the tool
and this is something i recommend
and
i want you to participate to explore and
to support this community not just
consume the tools
because we're going to be given tools to
begin
in this which are going to help us but
we must contribute and i invite you to
do it
when because it's going to be a
difference because when what you provide
is going to be used by the community and
thanks to this element
and thanks to universal program plugins
we're going to have official elements
within documentation and also
third-party elements
created by you or by me who also want to
contribute
this is a very interesting topic
why not and thinking in this big
standard in this big resource that we
allowed us to have what we
call that are the tools that is the
theory inside the community a piece that
will be
already
typed and we can integrate and work with
our resources that bite us already gave
us so these are the main features the
fully typed app is so
let's talk about
uh detail that let's talk about
which problems a
vita solve what is the particular need
that we are going to have or why do we
need to take into account that this is
key this is key so we can
have all the advantages okay i want to
mention to
i'm here to
solve something in particular so before
this was available for the browsers
there were no way to write a javascript
in a more friendly way so that's why we
use this resources web parcel among
others and these help us to use our app
so we can have a more
friendly structure easier to read and
with this we can prepare our project
with our
leading of our application but this
was a very important apart so nowadays
we use these concepts
and we implement it in a correct way
because the imaginary
the majority of the project we use this
as the predilect or our favorite tool
and
with this you have to
work with the processing of the models
and with this
all in a big pro
process so therefore this is like a neck
bottle when we prepare our projects so
there is when we have raised
some resources that will
help us and with a role is part of this
bell is a project that in some way is
preparing us so we can implement in a
native way the script models and then to
have the next step so what we
want to implement is this is something
fundamental
and we are going to have a better
performance a best resource to keep
going
so this problem byte is already working
on it they started implementing inside
view and nowadays we have a tool not
only to work with view but any type of
library that you are using right now
angular
views belt light element react among
others and also configurate with a
typescript or vanilla javascript this is
important to remember because with this
we have a big value it's not thinking
just for one tool but it's an open
it's open
so when we implement this model in a
negative way we can work better and as i
already mentioned we can integrate with
this build and with this we can work
faster
in that
process because we are working with
another languages and of course that is
a
a very very good thing so let's try it
as i already mentioned there are some
technologies that are supported so this
is not linked just to one
even though
was born in a very uh
spotted point as evangel mentioned is
open for you as a customer
to create project in different
technologies
according to your needs for example
react project angular product
vanilla javascript as i already
mentioned so i love this this is
something that i explore because
recently i've been working with element
i like this
concept and
i'm
fan of as well and react on my daily
life because i collaborate with this
type of project so
if i only have one resource well
this is important for this tool
i've started to migrate some project
with this resource because i love this
one versatility and one of this project
is the one that you are
watching here this type of presentation
this research that what is vite well are
distributed with this i started to
migrate some other project with the
visuals so you can start like this
this is a mixture of comments for
example some swell tools
and other ideas
and this is supported thanks to these
technologies and but therefore i'm very
very happy about this
and i want to
invite you
to be part of this community there's a
lot of community there's a lot of people
using this resource so
log in this is the link it's not so
friendly but you can take a screenshot
and that's it
so
let's take the picture and so you can
remember the link
and you can access to our community you
can
know everything that is happening and
you can collaborate
this is an opportunity
you can start with a translation area
and then resolve
some issues or bugs
and you will acquire a professional
level because you are looking for that
so take it this into account and very
fast let's see
the twitters
i will
show
you we are listening and this tool
is
built directly with this tool
this is a clear example of how to
implement
and to integrate in something like this
in this video for example
and to close my presentation and
open to the q a session
let's talk about
com
the
competency and i want to mention this so
you can have the idea and you say well
goodbye parcel and i will change
and i will go to bite no just give a
chance
understand how this works
and
the main feature small world faster
when you start your server
how the hot model works better it's more
friendly so all these features with
other standard resources of script or
typescript
at the same time with the swap d full
product on elements so again
an opportunity to adapt to these tools
but this doesn't mean that will take
place to another is just one more tool
and remember vite is implementing new
concept and at the same time
incorporating role
this means that well doesn't mean that
tomorrow
this is only one solution is not one
more option and let's also
remember explore and know
resources tools
so you can be a better professional
and as i mentioned i already have
several projects with different
tools
and i
profit from all the advantages
and when do you are going to have this
need well when you are part of the team
to solve
a lot of needs and you can
say
hey you know already bite and you can
explain
all this concept and
you can have all the context and in what
in which moment are you going to take
the advantage well
don't
don't say
pro
[Music]
just one tool
we are pro software engineer we know the
technology
and we know the advantages of all of
them
i want you to invite you
don't put this versus the other as you
are seeing in this
picture
but know the tool and take it to the
next level
that's one of my
inputs for this talk
and you can have it in angular react as
well as single what
anything that has to do with our
ecosystem
don't waste time to know which is more
or less just again give it the
opportunity to all the tools and know
all the tools
all the advantages
to have a very fast deploys and to again
a friendly job
and as i already mentioned
i
want to be ready for all these
environments to perform my projects to
teach others and currently
i like to teach with this and some
courses
and with these courses i
start to
show this tool
again spell react and all of them
and with all of this i thank you for
being in this talk
and my name is oscar barajas and
also known as gngx and this was my
experience and advantages with this tool
you can find me in all my social media
that you are watching in this slide
if you are in the crypto world you will
have the url
in order to know about this ecosystem